where you break everything down into a
small parks as possible called atoms and
then you can use those atoms to build
more complex parts called molecules and
then organisms using molecules etc etc
when developing a common UI library this
methodology works very great with react
you can make components share them and
at least for my part
having the atoms and molecules as the
common part makes sense while organisms
tend to be more the main specifics of
those will probably be more useful
implementing in the project level and
you might be asking so what is storage
oh actually this is storage so I've made
this presentation inside storybook it's
this handy little tool it's a UI
development environment where you can
make your react components completely
independent of each other or any type of
project so let's start with let's go run
atom let's say your designer comes with
this pack this is an image with some
Styles some states fair enough you
implement it and there you have a button
with some hover States you can press it
and storybook will even give you this
type of action logger which you can add
to your button to see that it works and
you can even define predefined States
for the button like a red one or an
active one and you can even use this
handy function the show info
and you can see exactly how the button
is used and what type of props is
defined to the component so it makes
like a very handy guide for other
developers if they want to use a
component they haven't used before or
generally for anybody who wants to see
what type of components you have you can
even link one story to another one like
this button we'll go to the next one and
then this one will go back so you can
build up flows of different states your
components have I guess that's why it's
called storybook evil stories and you
can even use a handy little atom you can
add the story book called knobs or you
can make just one button but if you go
down to the knob section you can
actually on the fly customize the
property sent into that button or toggle
different states like disabled or active
anything you might like let's say your
designer comes with another spec for a
page title and a subtitle easy enough
now we have another atom so let's
combine those two to a molecule in this
case we made a header components which
uses the title subtitle and some buttons
again we can use knobs to customize it
on the fly sadly like sending an array
of another component you can't really
modify that with knobs but you can
change the text in the button for
example
and then you would make more molecules
more atoms and we package them in MPM
package which then we can install in any
project we might want to use those
components so we have have the design
pattern on multiple projects and the
nice thing also which would go for free
using storybooks is that you can build a
static version of storybook so I can do
that now if time - and if I build
storybook now building a static version
of itself
and if I open just a small server
locally and open the static folder boom
you have a design manual a showcase of
your components you can upload to any
static hosting site and show off your
components is it if it's you know the
customer wants to see them other
developers other colleagues anybody if
you want to try it you can look at our
short showcase at this URL but be warned
though that story book is currently not
very mobile friendly so you could
desktop so I would just recommend you to
check out sir book they have a couple of
atoms like this show info and the knobs
and they even have an accessibility atom
and version 3 was recently released with
web back to support yeah so we've had
very much very positive experience using
storybook in our projects thank you
[Applause]